Where are you, Ralph?
We'll be late for soccer practice, hurry!
Sorry, Larry.
I can't find the ball and my soccer gear.
I see.
We still have thirty-three minutes before practice.
We'll run some drills according to Coach Carl.
Weren't you looking forward to doing this last Thursday?
I was.
We'll be doing dribbling, long passes and a short field penalty box game.
Coach also wants us to practice on trapping and ball control.
Really?
We rarely practice drills on Thursdays but I guess it's for the better.
Right.
Then on Saturday, we'll do recovery runs...
...and practice striking long and close-range shots.
Hmm, interesting.
All right, I'll be waiting for you at the bleachers.
Hurry up if you don't want to run laps around the field.
Don't worry.
I'll be right over quickly.